>> TEMPORARY SOLUTION
BECAUSE CONGRESS GANT GET
OUT OF THE WAY.
>> THAT'S WHY I'M RUNNING
FOR CONGRESS.
>> 2018 MID TERMS SEVERAL
MONTHS AWAY.
PROTECTING THE BORDER AND
KEEPING AMERICANS SAFE FROM
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
AS FOR THE DEMOCRATS, WELL,
SEVERAL DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES ARE ACTUALLY
CALLING FOR THE ABOLITION OF
ICE.
DON'T BELIEVE MOVE?
WELL, RANDY BRYCE
CHALLENGING PAUL RYAN
WISCONSIN'S FIRST DISTRICT
RECENTLY JUST TOLD THE TRUTH
AND TOLD "NEWSWEEK," GOAT, I
THINK THAT ICE SHOULD BOOL
ISSUE WILLED AND EXPLORE
WHICH AGENCY COULD CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT END QUOTE.
JOINING ME NOW IS DAVID
WARD, A FORMER ICE AGENT WHO
ALSO WORKED ON THE BORDER.
DAVID, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME DEMOCRATS CLINGING TO
THE IDEAS GETTING RID OF ICE
GET RID OF OUR PROBLEMS.
>> WE LIVE IN A GREAT
COUNTRY WHERE PEOPLE CAN RUN
FOR A CONGRESSIONAL SEAT AND
MAKE A STATEMENT LIKE HE DID
TO ABOLISH ICE, WHO DOES HE
EXPECT TO WORK IN THE
INTERIOR OF THE UNITED
STATES TO GO AFTER CRIMINAL